good evening everyone thank you very
much for joining us tonight it's my
pleasure to introduce beth harpaz miss
harp has has been a staff writer for The
Associated Press for 13 years for two of
those years she covered Hillary
Clinton's campaign for the United States
Senate her stories on the campaign
appeared in newspapers across the
country the stories that didn't appear
in the newspapers the funny ones the
personal ones the intimate ones are what
you find in her entertaining and
insightful new book the girls in the van
please join me in welcoming Beth hard
pass thank you thank you all for coming
thank you for having me here Barnes &
Noble and thank you for taping me c-span
and thank you to st. Martin's Press for
publishing my book my name is beth
harpaz and I covered Hillary Clinton's
Senate campaign as a reporter for The
Associated Press I wrote the book for a
couple of reasons um one of them is that
i found out that politics is very funny
you know i think a lot of books that are
written about politics are kind of dry
and ponderous and you know heavy tomes
of analysis but i wanted to capture all
of the jokes the inside jokes the silly
songs the fun and games and there's a
lot of it that goes on politicians know
that it's a game and journalists know
that it's a game to and I wanted to let
the readers know that as well when you
write stories for the Associated Press
you write them very straight if you
cover Hillary talking about taxes you're
at a story about taxes but when I would
go back to the newsroom the story that I
would tell to my friends was what
hillary was wearing or you know how bad
the food was or you know that everyone
in the audience fell asleep or that she
did something incredibly clever that you
know no one imagined she would be so
brilliant and she blew us all away
because she came up with a really
wonderful line or knew all the details
of you know nuclear weapons and that's
something that I wanted to capture in in
the book the stuff that didn't go into
the newspaper stories but that I thought
people would want to know about um I
also wanted to capture the historic
aspect of this campaign hillary was not
only the only first lady to ever run
and when elective office she's the first
woman in New York to win a statewide
office we have had female lieutenant
governor's but like vice presidents they
share the ticket with the governor you
don't get to vote for them separately
and Hillary is the first woman in New
York to win you know either Senate
governor or State Controller a lot of
states have been ahead of us on this for
years and years main had a female
senator back in the 1950s and today
Maine has two female senators but it
took until the year 2000 for New York to
elect a woman and I wanted to kind of
mull that over um why getting elected as
a woman in New York is so hard why do we
love Hillary why do we hate Hillary the
other thing that inspired me to write
the book was another book called the
boys on the bus this is a journalism
classic from the 1970s unfortunately
it's out of print I had to steal my copy
for my brother-in-law but you can get it
through the library I read this book
while I was covering Hillary and I
realized that a lot of things had not
changed in the 25 years since this
author wrote about the reporters who
covered McGovern Nixon reporters still
know every speech by heart that a
candidate gives after following them
around 12 hours a day for months on end
you get to know what they're about to
say pretty well you know the food is
really bad people get punch drunk
there's all these little inside jokes
and you kind of feel like you're in
summer camp after being on a bus for you
know 12 hours a day with the same people
but there are some things that have
changed one of them is technology in the
boys on the bus everyone is working
towards an evening deadline if they were
in South Dakota with McGovern a
helicopter would land at the end of the
day and they toss their tape to the
helicopter pilot and he'd take it back
to the station for the evening broadcast
now of course we have live satellite
feeds we have the internet we have
24-hour cable TV we don't have an
evening deadlines anymore we have news
24 hours a day and you know that because
your consumers of the news as someone
who had to produce part of the news you
know I was always phoning my stories in
by cell phone or typing them out of my
laptop people were getting emails and
pages on their blackberries and their
palm pilots and their their beepers so
that's increased the pace of the news
and it's put pressure on on political
campaigns
to create something for us to report
whether it's real or not um the other
big difference that I noticed in reading
the boys on the bus and in being part of
Hillary's press corps was that it's not
really the boys on the bus anymore it's
the girls in the van in 1972 it was
mostly men covering two male candidates
and their staffs were largely male in
1999 and 2000 most of the reporters who
covered Hillary in New York City were
women a lot of people on her staff were
women and not just the person who
carried her purse but also her speech
writer her policy analyst her top
strategist her campaign adviser and I
started to wonder how did this make
things different if at all some things
as I said were the same but there were
some things that were different I think
one of my favorite stories is the
bathroom story and i'm going to share
that with you read a little bit from the
book here as some of you probably know
Anna Quindlen was one of the first
reporters to cover City Hall who was a
woman she covered it for the New York
Times many years ago and she once wrote
in a column for The Times that as a
female reporter in the largely male
press corps covering City Hall she'd had
quote years of worrying that the best
stories were coming out of conversations
in the men's room between the mayor his
male staff and the male reporters so
this was our big chance to find out what
happens when the candidate goes into the
bathroom right one of my colleagues lara
jakes who worked upstate for the Albany
Times Union she turned 25 while covering
Hillary so this was one of her her big
the biggest stories she'd ever covered I
mean it was a big story for all of us
but especially someone that young she
actually followed the first lady into a
restroom on the first lady's very first
day on the listening tour which I'm sure
a lot of you remember so this was
upstate and upstate there were actually
a lot of men on the bus in fact Lera was
one of the few women on the bus that day
and this is what she told me she said I
kind of got goaded into doing it the
guys on the bus were like Jake's go in
there you got to see what's going on in
there solera followed Hillary and it a
rest stop
route 88 between Binghamton and Pinder's
corners which is where senator
Moynihan's farm was Hillary's personal
assistant Kelly craighead a funny lively
woman with long blond hair who could be
tough and protective of Hillary as any
Secret Service agent was standing by the
sink as the first lady emerged from a
stall they're both givin me the hairy
eyeball looking at my tape recorder
Lauer recalled I said something like I'm
not going to ambush you in the bathroom
I'm just here to make sure no news
happens when larek got back on the press
bus she wasn't sure if she let down the
guys or not I mean this was my first
real big political race she said they'd
send me into the bathroom and I don't
know am I supposed to ask her about
whitewater or what I'm thinking what if
I blow this we've got a year and a half
to go in the race but I just don't feel
comfortable asking her questions in the
ladies room I kept thinking what would
it guide you lismore of Newsday also had
a ladies room encounter one day when we
were at the Waldorf she walked into the
bathroom saw kelly craig had at the sink
and realized hillary was in a stall
doing her thing I couldn't deal with it
she confessed when she came back to the
press area I just turned around and
walked out you did the nice thing I told
her you were just being human and I'm in
this Sunday's New York Times Book of you
there's a review of my book in which the
reviewer says that that's the big
difference between women covering a
candidate and men covering a candidate a
man might not have consult his colleague
at having blown the opportunity to ask
the big question well I don't know if
that's true or not because I've not been
in the men's room when those things
happen but I don't think that anybody
ever got a big story out of Giuliani and
the men's room at City Hall it's just a
hunch I guess another difference is not
just the style of uh you know how we
relate to the candidate as you know as
women but also what do we talk about
when we do talk to her there's a famous
story in another wonderful campaign book
the book called fear and loathing on the
campaign trail by Hunter Thompson we're
a hundred gets a big exclusive interview
with Richard Nixon the only problem is
the ground rules are that he can only
talk about football so he gets in the
back seat of this limo with Nixon but he
can't ask him anything
political it all has to be about sports
and I think my football moment with
hillary was a conversation we had about
potty training I may have written the
only political book in history that
actually is potty training in the index
um and I thought I would read you a
little bit about how that how that
occurred the phone rang late one night
it was my mother-in-law Leah Beth she
said my friend just called to tell me
that hillary was on Channel two News
talking about how you potty-trained
Nathaniel Nathaniel is my two-year-old
how is that possible what I said what
are you talking about my friend told me
she saw Hillary on channel 2 talking to
the Associated Press reporter about
potty training it had to be you why was
Hillary talking about that on TV well I
said trying to remember the conversation
I told her I potty-trained Nathaniel but
I didn't know the cameras were rolling
my mother-in-law's friend had been right
the lead item on CBS TV news that night
was a story about the new Hillary the
lead in was she's shedding her old image
and showing voters the kinder gentler
Hillary and the entire piece was about
how she'd invited us all to go have
coffee with her one morning after she
held a press conference I had just come
back from vacation that day I was glad
to see the other reporters I'd come to
think of most of them as friends a
couple of them asked me what I did when
I was away and to the two mothers of
young children in the group lismore of
Newsday and Andrea Bernstein of the
National Public Radio affiliate WNYC I
explained that I took advantage of my
rare sojourn as a full-time mommy to
toilet train my baby Liz had just done
the same with her youngest and Andrea
proudly announced that her two-year-old
was using the potty to all of a sudden
Hillary looked around at us her eyes
fixed on me I guess after covering her
for nearly two years she noticed my
absence over the past few weeks and took
note of my return hi Beth she called out
cheerily how was your vacation since I
just finished telling the potty training
story it was on the tip of my tongue it
was great i responded I potty train my
two-year-old you did what she said all
of a sudden it hit
I probably should have given a more
conventional answer like it was so
relaxing but now it was too late I potty
train my two-year-old I replied in a
tiny voice Hillary looked at me
expectantly as if she still wasn't sure
she heard me right then she repeated it
back to me you potty-trained your
two-year-old I swallowed and nodded a
second ago chatting with the other moms
in the press corps it seemed as if
talking about potty training was the
most natural thing in the world but now
I felt ridiculous I mean I had just told
the first lady that I potty-trained my
two-year-old what a stupid thing to do
what the hell was wrong with me but I
needed to worry now that Hilary realized
she heard me right she looked around at
the small group and said emphatically
with a big smile this woman deserves a
round of applause then she turned back
to me and said boy or girl bat boy I
answered not sure whether it was better
to disappear from the face of the earth
right then or soldier on boy that's even
harder she replied then turned her
attention elsewhere thank goodness when
I finally got to see a tape of the
channel two segments the new Hillary I
saw why Marcia Kramer had included the
exchange the point was that hillary was
trying to make connections with us to
humanize herself and when she dropped
the formality and the Regal air she
could be warm and funny and caring and
yes even at ease in a conversation about
potty training I still felt slightly
foolish but I couldn't help but wonder
if it had been Chuck Schumer or al
d'amato or Mayor Giuliani that I was
covering instead of Hillary and one of
them asked me how my vacation was what I
have talked about potty training and if
I had would they have bothered to
continue the discussion as if it were a
perfectly legitimate topic the way
Hilary did or would they have put me in
a slot in their minds for keeping track
of Monteleone balanced reporters and
moved on to someone else
um I actually talked a lot in this book
about being a working mother I think
that we we we talk and we write a lot
about working mothers as a phenomenon
and we you know there are statistics on
it and how much do they make and how
many of them are there and what age of
their kids when they go back to work but
I don't think too many people actually
write about what happens when you know
you get home from work at six o'clock
after working a long day and the little
one needs a diaper and the big one has
homework to do and you have to make
dinner and then the phone rings and it's
your office and you know they need to
talk to you about something and you're
trying to do two jobs at once I am I
often thought of myself as Brenda
Bombeck while I was covering this
campaign because when I was a little
girl I always used to read the comic
strip Brenda Starr which was about this
glamorous redheaded reporter and I
always thought wouldn't it be great to
grow up and be Brenda Starr but then
when the reality hit of you know trying
to cover Hillary and raised my two
little boys I usually felt like uma
Bombeck because inevitably the water
would boil out of the pot or you know
something i would step in the cat vomit
on the way into the apartment after a
long day at work or I would be filing my
story on the cell phone while pushing
the stroller down the street something
like that I wanted to read you one of my
favorite Brenda Bombeck moments where
I'm trying to pretend that I'm a
hard-working reporter but actually I'm
Imani November 24th 1999 I'm standing on
the front steps of the apartment
building where I live shouting into my
cordless phone it's nine o'clock the
night before Thanksgiving cold and windy
and dark I'm talking to a guy named
David Rupert who dated Hilary when she
was in college he'd been interviewed in
a new book Hillary's choice by Gail
Sheehy and did an excerpt that was
released before the book came out he
hinted that Hilary might have smoked pot
hinted it by saying she hung out one
weekend in 1969 with a crowd in which
quote some of us were inhaling unquote
but he refused to actually come out and
say she partook quote I don't have to go
there but you can read between the lines
he told Gail Sheehy so one of my editors
called me at home the night before
thanksgiving to see if i could find
David Rupert and get him to clarify the
story
so now I have a pencil in one hand my
reporters notebook in the other and my
left shoulder hunched up to keep the
phone from falling and I'm trying to pin
this guy down one way or the other as to
whether he actually ever saw Hilary
smoke pot look it was very very kind of
you to return my call I say in my most
urgent yet polite yet assertive yet
ingratiating tone of voice the tone I
reserved for people like this people who
don't know me from a hole in the wall
people who for some ungodly reason agree
to speak to me what if they had any
sense at all they'd be slamming a door
in my face or hanging up but I just
really need you to answer one question I
say and then I won't take up any more of
your time did you ever see Hillary smoke
pot I just need a yes or no answer and
then we'll be off the phone I glanced up
as I talk to make sure my two little
boys haven't gotten run over you see
they're chasing their soccer ball in the
street there they are two little blonde
blurs darting around the park cars in
front of the building a street lamp
illuminating their game no no you can't
do that the big one Danny yells to his
younger brother Nathaniel as the little
guy picks the ball up with his hands no
hands you idiot how many times do I have
to tell you and soccer there are no
hands Danny runs over and kicks the ball
away from nathaniel back to his own turf
Nathaniel looks up at me a tearful pout
forming on his fat little face as he
stands in the pool of light from the
lamppost I'm trying to pretend in this
phone interview to be a normal
hard-working journalist apartment the
kids would have blown my cover in an
instant screaming for this or that and
me with no way to tune them out so I
brought them out in the front steps
hoping they would entertain themselves
for just a few minutes without pestering
me while I did my job but now with Danny
yelling at Nathaniel and Nathaniel about
to cry my cover will be blown mommy the
little one screams and then lets out a
whale I give Danny my angriest look the
one where I make my eyes really big and
scrunch my lips up then I put one hand
over the mouth of the phone and say stop
it now while wagging the finger of my
other hand in their direction then I
turn my back face the door of the
building and try to resume my
conversation are you still there I say
stepping back into my urgent sounding
yet sincere reporters mode sorry about
that we've been going around in circles
for a few minutes now me and Hillary's
ex-boyfriend with me restating the
question every way I could think of and
him not giving me a straight answer no
matter what i said i'm still here came
the reply and a tone both we read and
annoyed but you're not going to get me
to say what you want me to say if
hillary wants to tell you people in the
media or the voters whether she did or
did not smoke pot 30 years ago or
whatever it was that is entirely up to
her he immediately launches into the you
people in the media lecture I've heard
this one before the one about how we
shouldn't be chasing after all those
scandals we should just be sticking to
the issues the one that leaves out the
part about how readers are a lot more
interested in the scandals than they are
in the issues this conversation is going
nowhere fast I stick my pencil in the
wire coil of the notebook and turn back
to face the kids somehow Danny's managed
to get the game going again he kicks the
ball to Nathaniel Nathaniel chases after
it and then pounces on it with his hands
no hands screams Danny he looks up sees
that he has my attention in one's mom he
won't play by the rules Nathaniel's
eyebrows start to crinkle again mommy
the cry echoes off the buildings across
the street I hear a window go up
somebody's calling Child Welfare to turn
me in Danny here's the window to and
he's now grinning with delighted having
caused a disturbance in the neighborhood
and Nathaniel's picking the ball up
holding it above his head and throwing
it into the street don't run in the
street ice cream and dash down the steps
to the curb I put myself in the space
between the two cars parked in front of
the building to bar any potential
recovery of the ball by the children and
turn my attention back to the phone
there's no point in wasting this guy's
time or mine any longer if he was going
to tell me about Hillary smoking pot he
would have done it already it's time to
wrap things up right well I appreciate
your calling me back I say abruptly now
in the tone of voice I reserved for
unsolicited calls asking whether i want
to change telephone companies have a
good Thanksgiving sir
and thanks very much for your time love
calling people sir I have managed to
learn to say it in a way that no matter
how polite it seemed it was also an
insult like when a cop refers to a
handcuffed punk as this gentleman I'm
just about to bring the kids inside with
me when I see one of my neighbors coming
down the street he's a lawyer who used
to be a newspaper reporter I guess he'd
been working late and was just now
arriving home he has two boys like me
but his wife doesn't work and his kids
certainly aren't outside playing soccer
in the dark the night before
Thanksgiving oh hi there Beth what's
going on he asks oh I say feeling
ridiculous all of a sudden I'm just I'm
just calling Hillary's ex-boyfriend to
see if she ever smoked pot he knows I'm
covering Hillary so it isn't completely
absurd just mostly absurd I briefly
explained about the Sheehy book and how
I had to call the ex-boyfriend and how
it's just one of those calls it has to
be made right there and then so I
brought the kids out and he looked
slightly amused and maybe also slightly
relieved that he's given up journalism
for a more civilized profession like
being a lawyer we say goodnight and I
take the boys inside thank you despite
the differences between men covering
male candidates and women carry covering
female candidates there are of course
similarities between the girls in the
vent and the boys on the bus and one of
them is the silly songs that reporters
makeup on the campaign trail I wanted to
share my favorite song with you and
you'll have to forgive my singing which
is not perfect you probably all know the
routine and Annie Get Your Gun where
she's vying with a male sharpshooter and
they start singing anything you can do I
can do better well on this campaign the
candidates were vying for Jewish votes
you know about as hard as they could
every day either Hillary or her opponent
Rick Lazio was off to a synagogue or a
Jewish nursing home or a Jewish school
and it just got to the point where you
know every day we were talking about
Israel and get ish and this and that and
so we made up a little song to go with
it which was any Jew you can woo I can
woo
better I can woo and eat you better than
you know you can't guess I can't educate
I can and so that kind of became our
little theme song for the the days when
we were slapping around to nursing homes
and synagogues and all that I have a lot
of funny stories in the book about this
whole vying for the Jewish vote of
course everybody knows the Suha Arafat
thing I don't need to go into that but
um I thought you'd be interested to hear
that Hillary once took a Yiddish lesson
let me tell you about how that went hmm
a memorable episode in Hillary's
campaign for Jewish votes occurred when
she visited a nursing home for Holocaust
survivors in Queens with Tom Lantos a
California Democrat who is the only
Holocaust survivor to ever serve in
Congress Hillary told the nursing home
rent residents that Lantos had been
cavalia about his grandchildren now
selling is a Yiddish word that means
gushing with joy and pride Hillary had
used the word appropriately but her
pronunciation was all wrong val is
properly pronounced as one syllable with
the taking no longer to say than the
flood in flute but Hillary could only
say it improperly as Cavell I thought
maybe she was taking her cue from Sally
Field who'd bantered with the Jewish
union organizer in the movie Norma Rae
by muttering kvetch kvetch kvetch but I
later found out that the first lady had
a my fair lady style coaching session
with her Jewish staffers during a
routine conference call it had been her
idea to use the word fell but she knew
she needed a lesson on how to say it
she'd impressed her Jewish aids at other
times with her pronunciation of other
Yiddish words getting the guttural hot
in hutzpah just right during a debate
with Lazio and casually but correctly
using the word shul Yiddish for
synagogue at an event at the White House
so from her point of view using these
words showed she had a certain comfort
level of Jewish culture and maybe it
even earned her a brownie point or two
for trying to fit in but mastering the
pronunciation of val right turned out to
be a lost cause ha ha it's one syllable
can't you hear it the aided told her on
the phone
vukovar she replied that's what I said
my other favorite not very well known
Hillary story um actually shows how
smart her campaign was about a lot of
things um this a lot of people asked me
is this a pro Hillary book or an anti
Hillary book and believe it or not it's
a neutral Hillary book I mean I I just
write what happened and sometimes it's
about a campaign screw-up and sometimes
it's about something really smart that
her campaign did sometimes it makes the
media look good and sometimes it makes
us look really bad but this particular
incident I think showed how clueless her
opponent Rick Lazio was about trolling
for Jewish votes and how smart her own
campaign became as the campaign war on
Rick Lazio thought that he sort of had
the Orthodox Jewish community all sewn
up because he supported vouchers and a
lot of orthodox jews and their kids to
yeshiva so they would love to have a tax
break but what apparently his advisors
didn't realize is that if you bring the
media to an orthodox event the women are
not going to be allowed in unless you
make arrangements beforehand now I have
covered the Orthodox community in New
York for many years for the AP and
usually someone is savvy enough to call
ahead to the rabbi and say okay we're
going to have some women coming in the
press corps and they can usually make
some arrangement they hang a curtain or
they give you a woman from the community
to kind of walk your in and tell you
what's going on I had never been
excluded from an event in an orthodox
community until I went to a sukkah
celebration with Lazio in boro park and
that night Lazio walked into this
celebration and all the men on his staff
and there were only men walked in and
all the male reporters walked in and
then a guy with a yarmulke you know went
like this and no women no women coming
in so we all had to stand outside in the
cold and didn't know what the heck was
going on and I was very angry afterwards
in contrast when Hillary went to
Orthodox communities she always they
always made arrangements for us so that
we could see what was going on and hear
what was going on sometimes she'd even
put a little announcement on the media
advisory saying you know modest dresses
advised because if you showed up with a
miniskirt
somebody might not talk to you I think
what what happened in this borough park
community is very telling about how
smart Hillary's campaign became
especially as time went on the next
night in other words the night after the
women in the press corps had been
excluded from this sucker party with
Lazio the next night one of Hillary's
Jewish advisors Matthew Hiltzik went
back to the very same neighborhood to
meet with leaders from the bubbles one
of the Hasidic groups who took a
celebration Lazio had visited and I had
been kept out of ironically it turned
out that the route to a political
endorsement from this group was not by
dropping in on an all-male gathering as
Lazio had done but through a meeting
with the chief rabbis wife known as the
rebbetzin she's the classic example of a
bold strong woman behind the man Matthew
told me he was given the honor of being
part of a group escorting the rebbetzin
to synagogue that night and on the
Saturday night before the election
hillary was invited to come to Borough
Park herself for a 90 minute meeting
with a group of bubba for men and women
Republicans with contacts in the
community pressured the rabbi's wife not
to meet with Hillary but the rebbetzin
did what she thought was right she went
ahead and met the first lady anyway
Lazio had stressed his support for
vouchers to the group but Hilary was
able to talk about other issues that
turned out to be equally compelling to
them housing healthcare and jobs in the
end Hillary got the bub of endorsement
um I'm going to read you one last
section and then I think I'm going to
take some questions and if any of you
have Hillary stories I'd love to hear
them I also brought some photographs
from the book and if anybody has any
questions about those I'd love to tell
the stories behind those photos the what
I'm going to read to you is um is
something that I hope I don't get in
trouble for we were just talking about
religion and the chapter that I'm going
to read you is about race and religion
and politics a pretty explosive mix and
something that maybe is a little bit
taboo maybe we're not supposed to talk
about these things or say these things
or say what really happens but like I
said I I just wrote
the way it was and I think part of the
reason I chose this chapter is because I
think it shows Hillary at her best as a
political animal I think it explains why
black constituents are the strongest
constituents that she and her husband
have and I think it shows the press
corps at our silliest which is also part
of my goal in writing this book the
chapters called keep going and the other
reason that I like this chapter is that
in the weeks since September 11th even
though we all made fun of Hillary's
little keep going phrase as you'll see
in a few minutes I often find myself
saying to myself keep going October
first 2000 it's a sunday morning and I'm
with Hillary and that means I'm in a
black church because that's where
Hillary goes every Sunday morning some
days we start with the seven a.m.
service and hit our sixth or seventh
church around mid-afternoon but today
the schedule is light just three
churches before noon and then I can go
back to the office and write yet another
story about the lovefest between Hillary
and the black community we begin this
morning at Memorial Baptist Church in
Harlem it's not one of the power house
churches Democratic politicians usually
visit but then Hillary overachiever that
she is isn't content to hit a half dozen
churches like a normal candidate instead
in the two months before election day
she goes to 30 black churches from
storefront Tabernacles where the paint
is peeling in neighborhoods where no
white politicians ever go to better
known places like Abyssinian Baptist run
by the Reverend Calvin butts a prominent
activist and power broker who once made
headlines by calling Giuliani a racist
as always the row of seats taken up by
the press corps it's just about the only
part of the church occupied by white
faces occasionally a black photographer
or reporter is part of the mix but today
we are not only mostly white we are also
largely Jewish and because it's the
Sunday after rosh hashanah we greet each
other by saying happy new year most of
the worshippers are on their feet
clapping singing and rocking to an
electric guitar piano and drum ensemble
driven by the steady happy jangle of
a marine lift him up the several hundred
voices sing as one and within minutes I
and most of the other reporters stand up
to clapping and swaying along with them
the music is irresistible still we are
interlopers journalists in a place of
worship and white people and a place
filled with black faces no matter what
we do we feel self-conscious soon the
booming sounds die away and we sit down
the Reverend Preston Washington gets up
in shouts let's give them all the news
and the congregation lets out a cheer in
response the reporter sitting next to me
gives me a look of bewilderment did he
just say let's welcome all the Jews now
I reply he said let's give them all the
news all the news as in the gospel not
all the Jews now Hillary appears at the
podium a small familiar blond figure in
her going to church navy blue suit with
the skirt hem falling just below the
knee it's the sunday version of her
black pantsuit her uniform for the job
she's assigned herself today a
tumultuous cheer goes up and a warm wide
toothy lipstick smile blooms across her
face she's gonna win declares the pastor
and we are going to come out in droves
for her whoo Hillary hoots as the
applause dies down and she looks around
feeling the love thank you for the day
the lord has made its her standard
opening line a riff on the song that
begins this is the day the lord has made
let us rejoice and be glad in it and it
goes over is big here as it does in
every other church he's ever said it in
my Baptist husband says good morning she
continues the reference to bill whose
popularity in the black community is
legendary unleashes another ovation she
throws out a few thank yous to local
politicians in the audience most of them
introduced as my good friends so and so
then she lowers her voices and eyes and
takes on a solemn aspect that is
immediately sensed by the congregation
which becomes completely silent and
respectful and still I want to thank you
she says in a
small humble grateful voice for the
prayers and support and good wishes
you've given me and my husband and my
daughter over the last eight years those
prayers have uplifted sustained and I
believe protected us a smattering of
applause and a murmur of acknowledgement
ripples through the congregation they
are flattered and impressed the First
Lady of the United States the most
famous woman in the world has not only
found her way to their small church on
115 Street this morning but now she is
thanking them that's worth coming to
church for of course the first few times
I heard Hillary thank her black
supporters for their prayers I didn't
know what she was talking about then one
day when I was standing outside a
restaurant where she was holding a
meeting a black woman who was part of
the crowd outside waiting to greet her
came up to me and explained it everybody
loves her husband she told me there was
so many churches that fasted and prayed
for him during the impeachment because
they believed he was a good president
he's human but he's for the people and I
think she's a very good wife to stick
with him people say she did it for the
power but she did it because marriage is
for better or for worse now I understood
I thank the woman and made a note to
spend more time talking to people on
street corners in Queens and less time
talking to political analysts on the
phone I tune back in to Hillary's speech
at Memorial Baptist now she's reciting
statistics from the Clinton
administration's economic miracle the
lowest child poverty level on record the
lowest level of african-american
unemployment on record more applause and
then the self-congratulations gives way
to a humble message in keeping with the
spirit of religious service but I don't
believe America is called upon to be the
richest nation she says pausing as a few
voices call back that's right i believe
it is called upon to be the best she
continues and i believe our best days
are ahead of us that's why I'm running
for the Senate I want to be part of
making that future and now we are about
to hear the press kors favorite part of
Hillary's standard Sunday morning sermon
she starts by noting that she's been to
all 62 counties in New York State and
that one of the many places she visited
along the way was a burn
to see the house where Harriet Tubman
lived after escaping slavery Harriet
Tubman Hillary says is my favorite
heroine in American history because when
she got to freedom she didn't say well
I'm free I'm just gonna sit back and
live the good life now did she know she
didn't several voices respond she
decided to go back to the south and
bring more escaped slaves to freedom
Hillary continues mm-hmm the worshipers
call back and now Hillary's voice drops
to a stage whisper she looks
conspiratorial II around the room we are
all on the Underground Railroad with
Harriet and Hillary everyone becomes
still again she tell people to meet her
at night in a swamp or a grove of willow
trees and she'd say if you hear the dogs
keep going Hillary says her voice slowly
rising yes the audience calls back I
don't need to take notes at this point I
just right keep going in my notebook put
my pen down and listen for the words
that I and every other reporter here
know by heart if you hear the gunfire
keep going if you hear the men shouting
keep going if you hear the footsteps
keep going she gets louder and louder to
be heard over the growing din but her
cadence is as perfect as a real
preachers every pause time just right to
allow for a response from the audience
we may feel that we don't belong here we
write white reporters sitting in the
back row but that white lady in the
front of the church she's at home she
knows how to reach this audience and
even though when you come down to it
this is just a sophisticated plea for
votes they sense that she respects them
it doesn't hurt her comfort level that
she spent years going around to churches
in Arkansas with Bill and it doesn't
hurt that she's been on the campaign
trail for over a year in the early days
of covering Hillary we talked a lot
about her tenure she'd drone on too long
she'd say the wrong thing her message
was clunky or vague but in politics as
in school there is a learning curve and
we're seeing the result of it right now
today the first lady has perfect pitch
and her routine is going over big time
with the fans we all have to keep going
until we are a just nation she says
practically shouting now as people begin
to stand cheer and clap they're loving
every word
out of her mouth but I need your help
and if you will help me I will be there
for you let's keep going let's have a
great big turnout in the election if you
fight for me in the next five weeks I'll
go to the Senate and fight for you for
the next six years thank you everybody
thank you so much the band starts up
again and the applause turns into
rhythmic clapping in time to the beat
the first lady and her entourage swooped
out of the church with us Jews and the
rest of the press corps scrambling to
follow and pile in the pres ban before
it pulls away I ended up sitting next to
Tish Dirk and who writes for The New
York Observer she catches my eye and
gestures for me to come closer to hear
something she opens her blue eyes wide
and the hint of a smile plays on her
lips I'm gonna meet you in the swamp
tonight at 6pm she says I admit it I'm
kind of slow when it comes to catching
on to the antics in the dance so I
honestly didn't see the next line coming
and if you hear the guns Tish says keep
going my colleagues are way ahead of me
from the seat in front of us someone
calls out what if we hear the man Tish
calls back keep going now I get it from
the seat behind us another voice says
what have we here the dogs everyone
joins in on the refrain this time keep
going I think of my biggest obstacles to
perseverance on the Hillary trail and
call out what if we have to go to the
bathroom keep going what if we haven't
had lunch keep going the other reporters
shout back keep going by this time we
are all cracking up pumped up and giddy
at our own cleverness this doesn't feel
like work anymore it feels like I'm back
in high school giggling with my
girlfriend's in the stairwell and as a
little ps2 that and to show you that
Hillary actually is a very good sense of
humor and can even make jokes about
herself which I think probably most
people don't realize hmm i'll just tell
you sort of the the punchline of it all
a few weeks later on a three-day tour
upstate Hillary's motorcade got two
Auburn whereas she had pointed out in
all of her church speeches Harriet
Tubman's house is located her press aide
Karen Finney told everyone in the press
bus that Hillary safely ensconced in her
own van ahead had something to say to us
she hooked her cell phone up to a
microphone and Hillary's familiar voice
came through
I thought we'd all like to see the
Harriet Tubman house Hilary said but
we're running short on time to the next
event so we're gonna have to keep going
the press corps collapsed with laughter
they also got a nifty little memento of
the joke a laminated press credential
bearing a picture of the press bus the
words on the road with Hillary on the
top and a tiny keep going written across
the bottom so I'd love to take questions
it's sort of like the post realm of this
book but if you remember the fallout
that she got when she appeared at the
the vh1 concert I thought it was
interesting because this was a benefit
event everybody was trying to be so the
somber and for her to get that kind of
venomous hatred in the kind of
environment that that was I was just
dumbstruck what do you think was going
on that's a very good question everybody
here at he's asking about maybe some of
you saw this there was a benefit concert
a few weeks ago it was televised on vh1
it was to benefit the survivors and
victims of the World Trade Center attack
many of the tickets had been given out
to the people who were hardest hit by
the Trade Center attack which of course
would be firefighters and their families
police officers and their families and
Wall Street traders and their families
and these are three groups that are not
exactly Hillary's core supporters you
know Hillary is a very polarizing figure
I think a lot of it has to do with the
fact that she's a woman and she's a very
powerful woman and you know this is not
her demographic I mean let's look at
there's a reason that there was not one
woman killed among all the firefighters
who died at the World Trade Center there
it's it's a it's a male profession you
know police police work is changing but
it's still largely male
Wall Street traders you know again there
were a lot of women killed in the World
Trade Center tech who worked in various
financial firms but Wall Street is still
largely a boy's game and you know a lot
of these people don't live in New York
City where her death supporters are they
live in the suburbs to me it reminded me
of the st. Patrick's Day parade that she
marched in two years ago you know where
she was just booed every step of the way
people were booing at her and screaming
at her I wondered if it was funny after
the vh1 concert I wondered if maybe her
staff had erred in allowing her to go
there I mean they maybe somebody should
have thought this through a little
better and thought who's going to be in
the audience here are these really
Hillary's people is it possible that she
could get a negative reception might
that be embarrassing but what's
interesting about what happens to
Hillary when something awful happens to
her is that sometimes it actually helps
her in a funny way and what I mean by
that is that and I think this may be
also has to do with her being a woman
Hillary's Paul numbers were never as
high as when she was the victim in the
Monica Lewinsky scandal I mean that was
when her approval rating his first lady
was highest we like to feel sorry for
Hillary and you know I don't know
whether her staff even thought that far
ahead like oh my god she might get food
and then oh well maybe that wouldn't be
so bad like it would be embarrassing but
then it would remind people of maybe why
they like her but you know on the other
hand if they had stopped to think well
she might get food it would probably
have been worse if she had turned it
down I mean imagine the story in the
paper that would have said you know
Hillary invited to speak at concert for
World Trade Center survivors says no so
in this case she probably had to go no
matter what and you know I mean I just
think it's the audience but it's
interesting because there was another
concert that vh1 did a few days later
where the audience was mainly the
fashion world and you know these are her
people and you know it was mainly women
it was mainly you know Manhattan and she
was you know cheered and applauded and
it was about as strong as
Hillary group can get but it is a very
good question and you know like I say it
was embarrassing for her but on the
other hand I think when things like that
happen to her it reminds the people who
really like her and admire her of just
what she's gone through and maybe
ultimately it's a win for her anybody
else any Hillary stories anybody has to
tell me anybody meet her or any of these
photographs intrigue anyone come on guys
make it easy for me good solid what's
politics about and went on scandal the
one on politics is how did she deal with
al shop then I raised the question was I
was reading an article about mark
Greene's loss and there are a lot of
people who feel that shop is directly
connected with this and the other one on
scandal uh what's with our marriage like
I know like she knows um the Sharpton
thing is really interesting and I think
you know looking at mark Greene and what
happened to his campaign I think he
could have learned a lot of lessons by
studying how Hillary conducted her
campaign for one thing I think mark
Greene ignored women to some extent and
I think he could have done a lot more
with that constituency she really went
after it it wasn't it was a constituency
that was ambivalent about her at first
but in the end they came over to her and
they are the reason that she won
especially upset were a lot of
Republican Women crossed the line to
vote for her but your question is about
Al Sharpton remember this campaign went
on for two years I mean it's the longest
Senate campaign on record it was a
Senate campaign on the scale of a
presidential campaign the beauty of
doing that is it gave her a lot of time
to learn and it gave her a lot of time
to get the tricky things out of the way
early on she met with Al Sharpton on
Martin Luther King Day so we're talking
january twentieth right of two thousand
but still here were eleven months before
the election you know it was the right
time to do it because it's martin luther
king day there's nothing controversial
about Hillary going to make a speech
at Al Sharpton's headquarters on Martin
Luther King Day right and she after what
she had a private meeting with him and
this way ever after he could never say
you know Hillary's dissing me Hillary's
ignoring me because she went to him she
went to his headquarters on Madison
Avenue 125th street and spoke to his
supporters and whenever she was asked
about it she could always say you know
been there done that you know I I I was
I already spoke to the Reverend Al
Sharpton I already met with him what was
interesting is that particular event
potentially could have been very
embarrassing for her right before she
came in the room someone else was
speaking whose name I actually forget
someone I had never seen before and he
told a story that was like Porter line
anti-semitic in which he kept sort of
spitting out the words the Jew the Jew
you know and like Hillary wasn't in the
room yet she was off wherever she was
and we're all looking at each other like
this is like a mophie oh my god Hillary
comes to Al Sharpton in an anti-semitic
incident is happening before our eyes
now what's gonna happen you know and I'm
but someone on her staff passed her a
little note I guess because she got up
there and she had this little piece of
paper she's looking at it and then the
very first thing she says is you know um
you know I want to make it clear that
you know I I despise any any any
division or you know the politics of
division and I despise anti-semitism I
reject anti-semitism and so for like
five minutes she gets up there and you
know says every which way she can I have
nothing to do with anti-semitism and
then she went on to talk about you know
civil rights and Harriet Tubman and all
that good stuff um so you know like I
said she got over that early on and she
did it in a respectful way so that
Sharpton could you know could sort of
hold his head up and not feel that he'd
been just he wasn't just she did make a
journey to him on his turf you know on a
day that's that's very important to the
black community the most important day
in fact was the day she chose to meet
with all Sharpton so I mean I think that
they handled that rather well and then
you know rather than saying okay al
Sharpton is the only way I get to the
black community she didn't do that you
know
she wore out the shoe leather going to
every black church and I mean as I said
in his chapter I mean she went I've
covered other campaigns and I've been
you know with Chuck Schumer and other
candidates to black churches around the
city I mean we went to neighborhoods
where there are no white people we went
into churches where no politicians have
ever been tiny little storefront
churches you know really fundamentalist
churches with you know 50 people in them
and Hillary would go there I mean she
wasn't taking any chances that anyone
would feel overlooked especially people
from her core constituency and they
repaid her respect and her understanding
and her loyalty by really turning out
for her an election day she had a very
very strong black turnout it was
obviously overwhelming for her but you
know more than the percentage of who
votes for the Democrat and who doesn't I
mean black voters voted three two one
from our green so why didn't win it's
the turn out that matters it's not the
black voters don't vote Democrat it's
that Democrats have to make them feel
like I understand what your concerns are
I'm going to represent you and she
actually you know another speech that
she often gave in black churches was
very interesting she turned her marriage
and her loyalty to her husband into a
metaphor for loyalty with the black
community she would often get up and say
you know the kind of person I am when i
say i'll stick with someone i will stick
with them and you know the first time I
heard her say that I was like I can't
believe my ears you know here's the
woman who's gone out of her way to avoid
ever referring to her marriage you know
and making any reporter who dared ask
her about it feel like a jerk and now
she's getting up in front of these
people in church after church after
church saying you know I'm the kind of
person who sits with Bill you know I I
wouldn't even leave my husband when he's
running around on me and that means that
through thick and through thin I will be
there for the black community it doesn't
matter what's going on in Washington or
New York I will be there for you and
people really related to that I mean I
remember the first time she said it and
we in the press corps were like she
couldn't have meant what I thought she
meant right and so we did you know what
we always do and we don't know what the
hell is going on we ask real people and
so we went outside and I started just
buttonholing the congregation the
churchgoers as they left the church and
I was like
um what do you think she meant when she
said you know when I stick with you I'll
stick with you and they were like oh
she's talking about Bill you know I mean
it was very clear to them what this was
a metaphor for for um so you know I
think that sort of answers the question
and you know as for her marriage I mean
you know I don't know what would she the
answer that she almost always gave when
she was asked about it and she wasn't
asked about it very much it was an aunt
a personal answer about you know I
believe in the institution of marriage
it's part of my my religious faith I
think it's important for my family
meaning chelsea of course and you know
it's like that lady told me the lady
that i quoted in my in my the reading
the thing I read to you guys um
according to Hillary marriage is for
better or for worse you know I guess
most Americans don't feel that way
anymore but you know one of the things
that I think it's not very well known
about Hillary's that she's actually
deeply religious I mean it's one of the
things I actually truly believe about
her if you read it takes a village it's
less a prescription for how to raise
children then actually an autobiography
of Hillary and she talks a lot about
growing up in a Methodist Church in
Chicago she says that her father prayed
kneeling by the side of the bed every
night I mean you know I don't know a lot
of white people in the Northeast that
can say their father prayed kneeling by
the side of the bed every night who
aren't lubavitch you know and I don't
think they kneel um and I think actually
that's part of why New York sort of had
a hard time relating to Hillary because
she comes from a different tradition
she's Midwestern she's a white
Protestant she's a religious white
Protestant without being you know a
conservative fundamentalist Christian
and so you know to some extent I accept
what she says when she talks about her
marriage what one of late in the
campaign they started holding these
little focus groups with women to try to
figure out why women were having such a
hard time relating to her and one of the
people who held when these focus groups
said you know that they would say to you
know women on the Upper East Side like
you know she made choices in her life
that you would not have made so what
does that mean that she shouldn't be
your senator because she stayed with
Bill and you wouldn't have um I mean I
think a lot of people just refuse to
accept
explanation for it and but you know on
the other hand I think it's also fair to
say she's very ambitious and you know
marriage is a partnership for all kinds
of things success in career is one of
them I think it's probably a lot of
stuff but there's got to be something
there because if nothing else when you
see them together in a political
situation they are definitely related it
may be that they are relating about
politics rather than love and I I never
did hear or say you know I love him that
was never one of the answers to why do
you stick with him on the other hand
when her brother got in trouble for
scandal gate I don't know if you guys
remember the press conference she held
in the Senate where they you know people
were saying you know your brother your
brother really screwed up you know is
your brothers still allowed to come to
see you and she said I love my brother
and it's it hit me all of a sudden at
that moment that I had never heard her
say all the time she was asked about
Bill oh but I love him you know maybe
that's too private or or maybe it's just
too hard for her to say I don't know
anybody else good wait for the mic I I
think one of the photos up there is
Hillary and Chelsea and I just wondered
what was your sense of her relationship
the mother and daughter dynamic and and
what role did Chelsea play in
campaigning right that would be this
photo I love that photo because I think
it it it's a metaphor for Chelsea's role
in the campaign she was to be seen but
not really we were not ever allowed to
talk to her we were not ever allowed to
ask her a question she was sort of a
campaign prop and so I liked the black
sunglasses and the black turtleneck and
the little you know confidential whisper
to her mom um there's another photo that
goes with that photo and that's this one
that's lazio with his two little girls
you remember that Mayor Giuliani dropped
out of this campaign in May about five
or six months before the election and
all of a sudden in came Rick Lazio this
very clean-cut smarter than your average
congressman from long island without
any scandals you know with apparently a
happy marriage and these two adorable
little girls and of course school was
over in a month and he started bringing
the little girls wherever he went and
they were like kittens they were just as
cute as could be and he really loved him
and and you know they really loved him
and they do things like you know they'd
hang out the bus window and say vote for
my dad and all the photographers would
take their picture well it wasn't long
before we were informed that Chelsea
would be joining the campaign I wonder
why um they told us that you know she
had so many credits at Stanford she's so
brilliant that she could take a semester
off and still graduate on time and you
know it was her dad's last a couple
months in the White House and she wanted
to be there for this historic period and
she wanted to be on the campaign trail
supporting mom but we also wondered if
it didn't have something to do with the
fact that you know hillary was sort of
when she was against mayor Giuliani was
like Hillary you know Hillary all by
herself this strong powerful woman all
by herself you know versus Giuliani who
also is never seen with his wife or
children but now of a sudden she's up
against a happy father with his two
little kids maybe it's time to show
Hillary the wonderful mother and I I
have never met a voter who didn't say to
me I think Hillary did a wonderful job
with Chelsea she did it exactly right
she kept Chelsea away from you in the
media so in a way Chelsea didn't have to
be interviewed by us for Hillary to get
the benefit of being seen as a wonderful
mother and reminding everyone of what a
great job she did with Chelsea on the
other and we and the press corps sort of
thought that was unfair I mean Chelsea
is a grown-up now she's not eight years
old and you would say to you know you
could say to Chelsea something like hi
Chelsea how's it going and it would be
like you hadn't said a word she would
just ignore you she just say was like
she was def like you hadn't said
anything I mean I don't think anybody
wanted to grill her on whitewater um but
you know we asked for many times and
were denied the opportunity to ask
simple things such as how do you like
being on the campaign trail with your
mother I mean I don't think that's real
controversial um you know it's
interesting because sometimes people
have said to me when I have given this
thing about how we in the press corps
thought it was a little unfair that she
could bring Chelsea along but Chelsea
wasn't fair game voters have said to me
that they really respect the fact that
Chelsea ignored us like does everybody
have to be you know a celebrity maybe
that's a choice Chelsea is making she
chooses to ignore the media good for her
you know it's not good from my
perspective but my perspective is as a
reporter um you know Chelsea was really
um into campaigning sometimes sometimes
she would really work the rope line with
her mother and she'd be like kissing
babies and you know hugging old ladies
and other times she seemed kind of bored
I remember one time one of the press
aides said to me she just asked me where
she could curl up and read her book so
you know I guess maybe politics is not
in her future I'm not sure there was one
incident that we all just hooted and
hooted about Chelsea and Hillary went to
a an old-age home in Queens and this
nice Jewish lady got up and said Oh
Chelsea we've watched you grow up what
love you so much can we just hear your
voice and you know we in the media like
yes yes and we were all like we had a
pens ready tape recorders on we're gonna
hear Chelsea talk Wow and so Chelsea
like gets up you know she's like looking
around like this and she goes hello and
we all kind of waited and looked at each
other and all the old ladies looked at
each other and then after a minute it
became clear that she wasn't going to
say anything else and everybody kind of
tittered for a minute and then it was
like embarrassing so then the old lady
got up again as in yellow thank you for
coming to queens Hillary or whatever and
they went away but you know somebody
told me it was like a metaphor for the
campaign we kept waiting for someone to
say something really important but
they're really never was anything to say
except hello and I mean you know I don't
think Chelsea is stupid I'm sure she
could say lots of really brilliant
things um but either she didn't want to
or she was sort of dumbstruck at that
moment she'd maybe she doesn't have her
mother and father's gifts for speaking
publicly or maybe as you know a voter
pointed out to me
II know upon hearing me tell the story
perhaps she chooses to say nothing more
than hello and perhaps I should respect
that I don't know anybody else it's good
in the pudding black culture it will in
the black culture it really doesn't
matter you know what anybody says about
the children or anything you can have 15
men in the room one woman leader aunt or
niece or cousin it's a woman she runs
the show that she decides who's going to
eat who's going to be what she's a
strong woman black women like it doesn't
matter what Bill didn't care he they
ignore him anyway they would ignore him
in the family he runs around so what
he's like the house will have a ball
will play cards but do test okay but I'm
lame I mean I so I noticed every little
thing let me say anything I made out at
night so I see images my husband's an
educator we're at the labor day parade
waiting on forty-fourth Street to wait
to start so much confusion you couldn't
even hear yourself think I couldn't even
drink my coffee around the bus comes
Hillary and I'm gorgeous black outfit
yellow sweater my husband very well
educated four degrees he says look how
smart she is I thought he meant to dress
her outfit but he met her intelligence
she walked that it was the kids around
running around my dad we're gonna start
buses bus driver police everybody got
quiet it was so quiet you could hear
yourself think and then walks the Queen
everybody stops this is what we came for
the parades were waiting for her to
leaders we forgot it was a labor day we
waiting for Hillary we didn't know it so
she stops the show and I think she just
makes people who like firemen police the
people who are really done that you need
them to save your life you need them I
don't feel I need them someone with
black woman right by me you need to
protect yourself but she makes you feel
like if you don't really think you're
really important you have to put it down
really quick because she's gonna take
your breath away I heard the tension is
gonna be on her well we asked tantric
aids and always we love it but maybe
everybody else didn't but she is the
show and I think her daughter is an
offer I really believe that I she the
point is so this lady was making is that
Hillary stops the show and I I agree
with that ice
thought again and again and again I i'll
never forget going to grand central with
Hillary one day and she was standing up
on the west balcony over by where the
steak house is and people I mean she
didn't say a word she didn't have a
microphone I mean you know how noisy it
is in Grand Central but within like five
minutes everybody knew that she was
there and they were literally thousands
of people had stopped down below in the
in the in the hall and they were looking
up at her and they started chanting
Hillary Hillary and it happened to be
her birthday and I guess someone knew
that because someone started singing
happy birthday and I mean utterly
spontaneously 3,000 people singing happy
birthday to Hillary and grand central
might one of the other people in the
press corps said she's not Hillary she's
a Vita so well I think I think I've used
up my hour and I thank you all for
coming and I hope you bought my book on
the first-time author and I I appreciate
your applause and your laughter very
much
thank you very much thank you for the
questions please do come up especially
if you have more questions and pick up a
copy of the book thank you